this is with us in New Hampshire hey
Chris welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thank you serve what's up well I heard
me I'm sweating I got myself debt-free
this past September paid off all my
credit cards student loans everything
and right now I'm currently selling cars
and my employer gives a $300 a month
vehicle allowance so long as you have a
vehicle loan through them and my my
father's mechanic there's a dealer
license and wants to because my car
doesn't pass inspection he wants to take
me this summer to go purchase a vehicle
at auction for like six seven grand cash
and I don't know if I should do that
soon the 67 grand put it aside so that I
can pay the vehicle off and purchase it
through my employer and let them pay for
it well they're gonna pay for it as long
as you work there but as soon as you
don't work there anymore you have card
debt no I'm not going into debt with the
promise of your employer paying a car
allowance not a chance
pay cash for your cars pay cash for your
cars the rest of your life if you want
to be wealthy okay yeah I'm just
starting out I mean I'm 25 I was very
lucky I made fifty five thousand dollars
last year I was I'm very happy here's
what happens okay inevitably you go buy
a car based on the three hundred dollar
payment that you're supposed to be
receiving from them you take out a loan
and something happens that you leave
that job six months later now you have a
car loan but then I'll take the money
that I was gonna go purchase at auction
and just pay it off yeah best laid plans
of mice and men though you're gonna get
yourself in trouble trying to play the
one foot left foot and just don't do it
just stay away from it
if you'll just stay away from dad and
keep the risk low in your life and keep
handling your money well Hank you've
obviously got to get from making money
and continue to make money and manage
the money well and don't try to do
something where you're tricking
something into happening no I'm not
gonna do that absolutely not I would
never take out a car loan and I would
never take out a car loan because the
company gives you a car allowance it is
a trap
you are stepping up on the rug and when
you do they're gonna pull it you're
gonna go down the hole down the hole
down the hole you do not want to have
this experience please just pay cash for
your car your dad's on the try track
save up pay cash for your car save up
and pay cash for your car he knows how
to buy cars at the auction and he knows
that about cars he's a mechanic that's
the guy you need to be listening to your
dad's the genius in this equation thanks
for the call brother appreciate you
joining us